a new push to repatriate mahindra
refugees from Bangladesh to their homes
in Myanmar has apparently ended in
failure after no one turned up to board
the waiting buses Myanmar is given the
go-ahead for more than 3,000 refugees to
be returned to their home country and
issued them with documentation but none
of them have yet chosen to follow
through that fearing what might happen
to them upon their return
this is bangladesh's second repatriation
attempt after a previous push that was
in November failed some 750,000 of the
persecuted Muslim minority fled a
military offensive in 2017 in Myanmar's
Rakeem state let's find out more about
this now I'm joined by DWS Naomi Conrad
she's at a refugee camp in the city of
Cox's Bazar that's in Bangladesh the
only good day to you why are the people
where you are refusing to board the
buses and go back to their homes
potentially because they don't trust the
government of Myanmar to actually
provide them with safety to give them
their lands back you have to remember
this made this Muslim minority has gone
through what some people term close to
ethnic cleansing their villages were
bombed in some cases women were raped
they simply don't trust the government
back in Myanmar to provide the safety
and to provide the human rights that
they want a lot of people say once these
beasts and their demands have been
fulfilled they would go back but at this
point they all prefer to stay here no
and we talked to and no one who's talked
to the UN so far wants to go back
willingly okay now you've been at the
the refugee camp we can see part of it
behind you there at Cox's a bazaar one
of the people there been telling you of
what are they saying about the living
conditions and what have you been able
to see for yourself there
the living conditions are difficult I
mean it's not quite as far as two years
ago so there's basic sanitation there's
bed stick education but basically
there's nothing to do for young people
and also at night once all the aid
workers leave the aid workers convoys
leave here about 4:35 it's completely
different it's dangerous criminal gangs
drug traffickers are active we've heard
people who tell us of abduction and
people have been killed so it's not safe
once the aid workers leave there's a lot
of frustration but as I said people
prefer to stay here than to have to go
back to Myanmar
okay that says a lot doesn't it them but
what needs to happen though to ensure
that the refugees where you are you know
are able to return safely to Myanmar
that's that's certainly in the interest
of the people where you are at Cox's
Bazar and to a certain degree to the
officials and authorities and and
Myanmar as well so what these refugees
want is full citizenship rights they
want their lands back and if their
houses are feeling burnt they want new
houses but what is crucial here is that
UN monitors that the aid community has
to have access to the villages in
northern Rakhine that's to say they fled
from also some of the repatriation camps
at the Burmese government has said that
it was set up so far there have been no
delegations no journalists no
independent people who've been able to
visit these camp sir there's a lot of
fear around nobody knows whether the
promises that the Burmese government has
set up whether they will actually be
fulfilled Naomi thank you very much for
that
Naomi Conrad for us at the refugee camp
at Cox's Bazar in Bangladesh